ich könnte es wirklich jedem menschen
irgendwelche luxusgüter zu besitzen wie
beispielsweise eine geile uhr oder ein
geiles auto oder eine kleine wohnung ins
haus keine ahnung was auch immer wenn
sie allerdings damit ekelhaft prallen
und ist die ganze zeit erwähnen die
ganze zeit zeigen dann ist einfach nur
abartig und da dachte ich mir das kann
ich noch schlimmer werden als dass leute
täglich bilder mit ihren uhren hochladen
oder mit ihren geilen abend geht's oder
keine ahnung was er mich habe ein
mädchen auf instagram and eggs namens
wildheit und wildheit ist neun jahre alt
ich will gar nichts vorwegnehmen freunde
wie reagieren heute zusammen auf das
videobild flexicon instagram
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist ein bmw i8 das ist ein
sportwagen den bekommt man 138000 euro
und dieses mädchen ist einfach neun
jahre alt und sitzt in diesem auto und
tut so als wäre es ihr auto aber wir
schauen mal weiter cool
wahrscheinlich einfach dein vater außer
rose tasche geklaut du bist so ein
ekelhafter mensch sie ist neun jahre alt
und ihren eltern gehört irgendwie dieses
auto will mit neun jahren darf turnieren
zwar auf der welt autofahren und habt
ihr nicht bloß ein auto kaufen und sie
hampel darauf herum und sagt hey guck
mal das auto hat flügel schön ich habe
die schlüssel und ihr werdet alle nie so
ein auto sehen
fick dich einfach wir wissen langsam
dass die neun jahre alt bist wie sagt
doch dass sie in beverly hills wohnen
und mit ihrem ja darum fahren wird nein
du bist 9
du sollst verdammt nochmal pokémon
karten tauschen
[Musik]
ich glaube das was scripted aber auch
wenn skripte das ist ekelhaft
dass solche erwachsenen leute da
mitspielen mädel du bist neun jahre alt
alter ich weiß nicht ob das was du
machst einfach nur irgendwie der
schauspieler ist oder aufregende rolle
spielst oder keine ahnung was aber auch
werden es ist einfach scheiße hör auf
damit jetzt das mädchen von cash mehr
zeit und die hat irgendwie stress mit
ihr und da ist auch die neunjährige von
gerade ich weiß nicht als die jetzt
gerade abgeht auch irgendwie fahren oder
streit oder ich weiß nicht wer da
angefangen hat
wir springen weiter zum nächsten video
das ist sehr hart
[Musik]
ich da nicht falsch ich selber feier
klamotten übertriebenes und habe auch
ein paar goodies oder ein paar schuhe
die ein bisschen teurer sind aber bar du
gibst damit so ekelhaft
man merkt einfach richtig dass du die
sache nicht kauft weil du daran selber
spaß hast und selber gerade leidenschaft
für hass und des selber mag sondern du
willst einfach nur anderen zeigen wie
viel geld das kostet und wie geil du
dadurch jetzt bist du nicht ich will
dich nicht beleidigen weil du bist neun
jahre alt gehen kindergarten oder so
sie sagt zu irgendwelchen anderen leuten
hey bevor irgendwie scheiße über mich
verbreitet und bin verdient erst mal
euer eigenes geld ich weiß dass mein
hauptgrund im ganzen videos aber du bist
du darfst nicht mal dein eigenes geld
verdienen wieso fühlt man sich dort
sogar so was ich zitiere sie jetzt
massiv sagt sie es ist flex also sie ist
die jüngste flex drin ich weiß nicht nur
eine flex übersetzen soll auf deutsch
aber weil jemand der mit seinen gütern
mit seinen produkten die er besitzt
angibt und wieso ist man froh so etwas
zu sein
[Musik]
war klar dass dieser standard muss mit
dem geld wegschmeißen auch noch kommt
das ist
das kosten nicht 200.000 hauses ist eine
s klasse angeht dann vielleicht doch
unter hat sie freunde macht das kann ich
mir das sogar zutrauen
das macht keinen sinn ich will nicht
wissen was seine eltern von dir denken
wahrscheinlich fördern ihre eltern das
sogar noch bei seiner verrückten familie
also natürlich sie wird er wieder mit
geldscheinen rum und was alles aber sie
hatten iphone fix ist mir gar nicht so
aufgefallen mit 9
mit neuen hatte ich ein handy da saß ich
im bus und habe gekurbelt erst mal es
geht so nicht so wie du es gerade
gemacht hast das ist wahrscheinlich für
kokain oder so obwohl ich mir das auch
zutrauen würde so wie sie drauf ist aber
sie steht ja wieder an irgendeinem bad
mit ihrem iphone access meist geld rufen
sie sagt hey wir sind eine gern wenn du
stress hast also wenn ihr stress hat
dann zieht ihr wahrscheinlich zusammen
allein koks hey das ist doch echt
ekelhaft hat die ganze zeit sie arbeitet
so hart was arbeitest du mit neun jahren
du bist 9g verdammt nochmal pokémon
kartenspielen allein das sein bett so
viel kostet wie ein lamborghini
und ich meine normalerweise würde ich
sagen okay das ist eine floskel und es
stimmt ich habe dir trifft das zu dann
ist das einfach nur eine dumme
investitionen von geld
ich kann mir so was nicht mehr geben